وخمسمائة طائرة اف خمسة وثلاثين
ضمن برنامج تصل تكلفته الى واحد
وثلاثين المقاتل الامريكية لقب
الاقوى في العالم? بجانب انها
المتوسط تكرر الحادث ايضا على
حاملة طائرات لتسقط في البحر
ويتدارك الطيار الخطر ويطلق نفسه
خارجها لينجو بحياته. وكذلك في
العيوب الشائعة لها وقد نشر في
مقالة ان المقاتلة تتطلب برامج
البنتاجون رفضه عن قبول طائرة اف
خمسة وثلاثين الجديدة ليس بسبب
التجسس وذلك بعد ان تم اكتشاف ان
المغناطيس المستخدم في محرك
الطائرة وعددها اربع عشرة دولة.
وكانت واشنطن تخطط لامتلاك الفين
العيوب والاخطاء التقنية هذه
المرة وانما بسبب الخوف من
صيانة ذات دقة عالية ومتواصلة
ليضيف على ذلك تكلفة سعرها
هذا النوع بينها اكثر من
اربعمائة وستين طائرة تابعة
وسبعة من عشرة تريليون دولار.
برأيكم? هل تستحق طائرة اف خمسة
للجيش الامريكي وباقي الطائرات
على الدول المشاركة في برنامج
خبرا عابرا نأتي به من فيا له من
موقف مضحك. لن نذهب بعيدا. ففي
الامريكية الصنع والتي حصلت
عليها القوات الجوية الكورية
عام الفين واثنين وعشرين وبمدرج
للطائرات قرب محطة فورت وورث
على شراء كوريا الجنوبية لاربعين
طائرة من طراز اف خمسة وثلاثين
القدر يا اصدقاء. انتجت الولايات
المتحدة نحو سبعمائة طائرة من
مليار دولار. الحوادث والاخطاء
كثيرة ولكن دعونا نكتفي بهذا
غارقة ويتم ايقاف ثلاثمائة طائرة
منها والتي تقدر بثلاثة وعشرين
مؤخرا اكدت سيول ان مقاتلات
الشبح اف خمسة وثلاثين ايه
مليون دولار. وفق وكالة فايس
الامريكية. وتأكدوا ان هذا ليس
الباهظة والبالغة مئة مليون
دولار للمقاتلات الواحدة. ليعلن
خلال مهمة تدريبية. وتسببت في
خسائر لا تقل عن اثنين ونصف
عشر شهرا. وذلك بسبب اعطال
اصابتها بينما لم تمر اشهر قليلة
لبعض العمليات الامريكية. واما
في مطلع عام الفين واثنين وعشرين
بحر الصين الجنوبي للوصول الى
حطام مقاتلة اف خمسة وثلاثين
المقاتلة مصنوع من مواد غير مصرح
بها من الصين. اما الحادث الاغرب
انظمة قذف الطيارين على متن ثلاث
طائرات عسكرية امريكية الصنع.
محشوة بمعدات تصنف على ان سرية
وهو ما سعت بكينو لاكتشافه.
الغارقة. وبرغم العيوب التي ظهرت
فيها فان المقاتلات الامريكية
مقعد القذف والذي يعتبر طوق نجاة
للطيار في حالة حدوث اي خلل.
اثر اقلاعها في مهمة روتينية من
قاعدة جرين الجوية غرب ولاية
ايه ونشرها في البلاد. وبحسب
موقع فوربس الامريكي والذي تناقل
الجنوبية خرجت عن الخدمة مائتين
واربعا وثلاثين مرة خلال ثمانية
وعلى رأسها طائرة اف خمسة
وثلاثين مما ادى الى وقف مؤقت
يعاني الكثير من المشاكل.
نيويورك تايمز الامريكية.
خارقة نتحدث. عيوب واخطاء اف
خمسة وثلاثين. الحلو ما بيكملش
بسرعة تصل الى الف ومائتي ميل في
الساعة. لها القدرة على حمل
بمواصفات الخارقة تبدو اف خمسة
وثلاثين انها طائرة كاملة ومرعبة
واحد ومقعد واحد للطيار. ليس
بوسع اي طيار ان يقلع بها قبل
ذكاء اصطناعي يعمل على تحديد كل
ما يحيط بالمقاتلة من اهداف.
قادرة على تفادي صواريخ المضادات
الارضية الروسية المتطورة. كنظام
تطورا بالعالم. تتكون من
ثلاثمائة الف قطعة وبها محرك
فلوريدا. وكان هذا هو اول حادث
مؤسف تتعرض له الطائرة. والتي
والصواريخ الموجهة جو جو. بينما
تظل واحدة من اقوى مميزاتها انها
اضطر قائدها للهروب بواسطة مقعد
القذف الخاص بالطيارة. وبشأن
ولكن الكمال لله وحده. يشبهها
الامريكان بالطفل الشقي الذي
الصحيفة التي اشارت الى اشتعال
النيران في عام الفين واربعة عشر
لا تحتاج الى مدرج ويمكنها
الاقلاع عموديا. وهي مزودة بنظام
درجة. لديها اقوى محرك تحمله
طائرة مقاتلة في العالم. وتحلق
الدفاع الجوي الاس ثلاثمائة
والاس اربعمائة. اف خمسة وثلاثين
الامريكية مهددة بالغاء بيع احدث
مقاتلات اف خمسة وثلاثين لها
شروط والا فسنشتري من غيركم.
المقاتلة الاشرس في العالم. هي
كما يقول اهل مصر والزين ما يكمل
حلاه كما يقول الخليجيون.
الاهداف الارضية من بعيد. دون
الحاجة للاقتراب منها. هي قادرة
العام الفين وثمانية عشر من قبل
سلاح الجو لدولة الكيان. ولكن
الف دولار. لم ننتهي بعد. فرادار
الطائرة له مدى واسع يمكنها من
معرفة خمسمائة وذلك لكل من طاقم
الطائرة والمهندسين والطاقم
الاقوى والاشمل في التاريخ. تكلف
خوذة الطيار فيها فقط اربعمائة
خمسة وثلاثين. واليكم بقية
قصتها. من هنا كانت البداية
احدى المقاتلات الجوية التي
تنتمي الى مقاتلات الجيل الخامس
الارضي. هي ثاني مقاتلة من الجيل
الخامس تدخل الى الخدمة تتميز
دفاعية روسية ويبدأ هناك العراق.
الاتراك يرغبون باستعادة اموالهم
الاخضر لشركة لوكهيد مارتن
الامريكية والمعروفة بصناعتها
العسكرية العملاقة. والتي تتميز
بجودتها ودقتها في صناعة الاسلحة
التي دفعوها للاستثمار في اف
خمسة وثلاثين. وواشنطن ترغب
مقاتلة شبحية متعددة الاغراض
والقدرات وهي اكثر الطائرات
بذلك اول دولة في حلف الناتو
تحصل على منظومة اس اربعمائة
نيران الغضب تشتعل في صدور الغرب
وليس امريكا فقط. لتصبح تركيا
اربعمائة الروسية. الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان كان قد اعلن عام
العام الفين وخمسة عشر تكررت
الحادثة في اليابان. في البحر
الهليكوبتر هبطت للخمسة وثلاثين
لتهبط الطائرة ساجدة وغير متزنة
الجوية بتكساس وبتقنية هبوطها
العمودي تماما مثل طائرة
علمها. ليصنع الصينيون نسخة اخرى
منها. انها الطائرة الامريكية اف
العيون والسبب كونها الطائرة
الاغلى سعرا في العالم. صنعتها
الفين وسبعة عشر عن توقيع عقد مع
روسيا لشراء منظومات صواريخ اس
بتعويضهم بطائرات اف ستة عشر
لترد تركيا اذا كنتم لنا دون
والمضحك ايضا فقد اطلقت المقاتلة
اف خمسة وثلاثين نار على نفسها
خمسة وثلاثين الامريكية والتي
تعد اكثر الطائرات الامريكية
لكن في عام الفين وتسعة عشر
امريكا تصدم احفاد عثمان وتقرر
الروسية اس اربعمائة في صفقة
اعترضت عليها واشنطن وقالت انها
تركيا من برنامج صناعة طائرات اف
خمسة وثلاثين. وفي العام نفسه
يقول المصريون. نعم الكثير من
العيوب التي اخفتها امريكا عن
وبذلك يستطيع الطيار ان يرى محيط
الطائرة بمدى ثلاثمائة وستين
بالاضافة الى فرض عقوبات. غير ان
انقرة رفضت تقديم تنازلات لتتخلى
على حمل مختلف انواع الاسلحة.
مثل القنابل الموجهة بالليزر
صاروخين على الجناحين واربعة
صواريخ في جوفها. اي مواصفات
اكتشاف المعادية من مسافات
بعيدة. لديها القدرة على ضرب
عن صفقة الصواريخ الروسية مواصلة
المفاوضات بشأن دفعة اضافية من
وكالة رويترز تقر بوجود عيوب
محتملة في الخراطيش المتفجرات في
احتدم سباق مع الزمن بين
البحريتين الامريكية والصينية في
الاغلى عالميا رغم انها لم تخض
قتالا حقيقيا حتى اليوم?
هي عضو في حلف الناتو لا يمكنها
شراء السلاح الروسي. تطالب
بالمناورة الممتازة وتستطيع
تفادي الرصد من قبل الرادارات
المعادية. بها حزمة من اجهزة
الاستشعار المتكاملة والتي تعتبر
الاسرائيلي. ليتم استخدام خمسة
وثلاثين لاول مرة في القتال في
واشنطن انقرة بالتخلي عن هذه
الصفقة مقابل تزويدها بمنظومات
وصني هذه الطائرة خمس عشرة دولة
من بينها تركيا والكيان
تمثل تهديدا لمقاتلاتها الشبحية.
وليؤكد الامريكان ان تركيا التي
اربعمائة المضادة للطيران تقدر
بقيمة اثنين ونصف مليار دولار.
وليس بعيدا ترد تركيا على ذلك
القرار بشراء منظومة الصواريخ
تطورا. ووضعت استثمارات ضخمة
بشأن ذلك باكثر من مليار دولار.
عن اف خمسة وثلاثين. وتدخل
الخدمة حينها. تشارك في استثمار
قبل ذلك كانت تركيا قد طلبت شراء
اكثر من مائة نسخة من مقاتلات اف
الجوية والبرية والبحرية. لتكشف
الستار في عام الفين وخمسة عشر
وبالتحديد في العام الفين وستة.
ولايات المتحدة تعطي الضوء
اقوى محرك جوي. طائرة تسابق
الرياح بسرعتها. دول عديدة يسيل
وتسببت باشعال فتيل الغيرة بين
دول الناتو. الحلو ما بيكملش كما
المقاتلة الاشرس في العالم وحش
الجو الامريكي المرعب. صاحبة
الولايات المتحدة لتكتشف لاحقا
ان الصين تسللت في صناعتها دون
لعابها وتلهث لامتلاكها. طائرة
اشتركت بصناعتها خمس عشرة دولة